Some well known harmful teratogens
are viruses such as the flu or rubella.
Alcohol, nicotine, prescription drugs,
such as anti-depressants, or radiation.
It's interesting that all of these
are particularly dangerous,
during certain periods
of pre-natal development.
Viruses have a major impact
early on in pregnancy.
But not so much towards the end.
Specifically, if a mom get the flu
between month four and six of pregnancy,
the risk of schizophrenia increases
for the child later in life.
Now the odds only go from about 1% to 4%,
but it's a significant increase.
In addition, nicotine exposure
from maternal smoking
can lead to low birth weight
or even still birth.
So this shows that the developing brain
is really vulnerable to both environmental
stimulation and toxic chemicals.
That's why pre-natal care
is so important to a developing fetus.